I think we can all say that it's not
very attractive I don't really know what
you're going to have in common with each
other I do believe though that since you
are here on this channel you're probably
very elegant and cultivated and have a
brain going for yourself that you don't
really want to be with somebody who is
less intelligent than you just think
about what are you going to be talking
to this man about for the rest of your
life let's say you become married I
don't know I think life is too short to
waste with the wrong person make sure
you find somebody you have things in
common with do you think things in
common matter no okay what do you what
what what do you think matters I think
the way you were raised matters so like
what examples did they have of
relationships growing up and if they
didn't have that how like because some
people have just never seen successful
relationships so how would they have one